welcome to your mom's house
so what have you thought just plan your
these are submitted by fans yes okay
faggot I lied you're right the next one
that's a song I know what you're doing I
know next one's definitely a song god no
it's just playing but there's one thing
I know in this world sticks and cocks
and balls what are you doing now play
the next one next with a song for real
it doesn't do you not mind being in
something where the word nigger is
and that song no please just play the
next one that I have great man I'm the
president of the Dixon say no I'm the
president of the Dixon say no faggot
wow you're so you're so full of hate I
had no idea
you're so hateful you've finally got
sick of being the one that gets caught
all the time huh
yeah I got you you're such a shit turd
yeah you brought up road rules if
there's one thing I know in this world
sticks and cocks and balls
first of all blue band brought up Road
rules on his own sure you did
sure he said peaches brought look yeah
but he submits all the potential clips
and then you choose this time to play
well I mean it was a good choice you're
the worst